look at these absolute monstrosities
it looks like a little turd and it's
sank to the bottom
hello everybody it is me elise what's up
y'all i'm joelle
and today i'm challenging my friend
elise to make
only korean meals i am having my friend
joelle make
only gummy and dishes i am ethnically
half chinese half korean but raised in
the states pretty much my entire life
my ethnic background is ghanian both of
my parents are born and raised in ghana
i have
pretty much zero experience with ghanian
or just west african food in general so
i'm
super excited to try the meals that
elise has written out for me i
definitely have a decent amount of
experience with
east asian foods but mostly japanese and
chinese
korean food it'll be exciting to make
whatever dishes joelle has for me
so the breakfast dish i chose for elise
is called patan and it's a korean
savory pancake it's actually a
relatively quick recipe so i hope that
it's not too crazy for elise you
effectively make a batter it honestly
can have a variety of things in it but
oftentimes we'll have things like
scallions green onions sometimes some
seafood it's really hearty so i love to
have it
just pan fried and with a fried egg on
top that's my favorite way to eat it and
then with a little bit of soy sauce
makes it really delicious in the morning
this literally smells
i'm so excited to eat this plus eggs are
my favorite food
let's get a taste
there are no words now that hits with
the egg
like this is something i could see
myself eating for breakfast on any
like regular day now i'm excited for
lunch because if breakfast was this good
all right so the first dish i'm having
joelle make is beaufroat
beaufort isn't necessarily a breakfast
dish but you can kind of think of it as
a ghanaian donut
you have your flour sugar nutmeg
different spices
and it's kind of just a nice sweet light
dough
that you can have pretty much anytime
but i often have it in the morning
the trickiest part about beaufort is the
technique
that doesn't look right what did i do
wrong again
the dough you got to scoop it up kind of
swirl it in your hand and plop it
you just got to plop it right into the
hot oil
you got to get it formed into these nice
round balls that's how we typically eat
it
and it's not easy but i hope that
joelle is able to do it and that she
likes it okay i finished my breakfast
and i am so
excited for these they smell incredible
making these definitely takes practice
like first couple tries was rough but
then after a while they started getting
rounder
oh look at that
danielle's gonna try some oh it's good
right yeah daniel never likes my cooking
i mean i would totally make these and
bring them to like a brunch or a party
or something
and like serve these for people just
kind of have this finger food and it's
super good
alrighty for lunch for elise i chose to
have her make tendency
which is one of my favorite korean soups
it's
actually really similar to miso soup but
the soybean paste that you use as the
base of the broth is fermented so it has
a really strong rich flavor
can smell a little funky sometimes which
i think scares people off but the flavor
is incredible and so umami and you can
add really whatever you want to it
i like to add a lot of veggies some tofu
and
just you know all those fixings like
zucchini mushrooms whatever you might
have
it is super rich and i always have it
with some rice because it's quite salty
and so when you mix the rice in it's
just like so satisfying and the perfect
balance a lot of people think of kimchi
jjigae as being like the og
korean soup but i feel like tenjangtike
is
extremely underrated and it is so easy
to make and
incredibly satisfying so this is the
tanjong jigae yes
this is a soup i've never had fermented
bean paste before
okay very very very
umami type flavor like it's very deep
it's a deep deep flavor it's deep
it was pretty easy to follow the steps
like soup is always easy you know soup
is always pretty easy and this one's
really good
yeah okay so the next dish that i'm
having joelle make for lunch
is freaking jalof rice
with asada plantains jaloff rice is a
staple
gummy and dish and very very popular
throughout all of west africa ghana
jalaprice is basically made up of
jasmine rice and some tomato mixture
tomatoes seasonings habanero peppers
different things all combined together
you cook the rice in the tomato mixture
and voila you got jollof rice notice
that something was smelling
a little a little burnt and though the
top of my rice
might look you know nice and ricey dig a
little deeper
and you can see the bottom it's like
entirely charred
rice in a pot it's hard guys okay it is
it is quite difficult
to get the perfect consistency of rice
you can eat it with meat on the side
like chicken beef fish but another great
side dish
is plantains and specifically kilo la is
what i'm having joelle make today
kellowelle is ripe plantains chopped
into little pieces
seasoned with salt and crushed red
pepper and other things if you want
and it's fried in oil and it's like
super crispy
on the outside but the inside is so
sweet and chewy
it's to die for besides being incredibly
embarrassed by my lack of culinary
skills and ability to make rice which is
a really fundamental um
dish of my culture as well because we're
babied
with rice cookers i'm really excited to
try my julep rice and kelly welly i
think it'll taste
really good despite it looking a little
burnt it's despite everything looking a
little burnt my plantains looked a
little burnt too but
the rice is like very
very savory with all the different
spices i love the kick
of the hot banana pepper the texture of
my rice absolutely questionable
i know there will be many people out
there flaming me for not knowing how to
make rice in a pot
hmm like the natural flavor of plantain
brought up by the salt
with a little bit of cooked from the
pepper is so good
didn't know you want to try yeah which
is good
okay for dinner elise gets a little bit
of a challenge
and i asked her to make kimchi mandu
which is just kimchi
dumplings dumplings they can be hit or
miss with how difficult they are
depending on your folding technique
there's some really easy ways of folding
it just in half which actually maximizes
the amount of stuffing you can put in
which is
what my grandma likes to do but you can
also get really fancy with it and like
fold them
and then make it like a round little
circle which is kind of the typical
korean way that you'll see them served a
lot in soups
i tried to fold it and now it's popping
the top
the top popped out they look like tacos
i finally figured out what i was doing
wrong
i let the dough dry out because i left
them out so they weren't folding
properly but now i figured it out
you can eat it with a bunch of korean
side dishes i feel like every korean
dinner
is never just one dish you always have
like you know maybe your entree but then
all the
panchan all the little side dishes and
then your rice of course which
kind of makes everything feel like a
feast which i love
dumplings you could have in a soup you
could have it steamed
or boiled or literally just like thrown
on a pan and then it gets nice and
crunchy on the bottom which is one of my
favorite ways of making it but
it's really good so i hope she has a
good old time with that all right i'm
finally i'm done with these
dumplings i think i did a decent job
with the shaping it took
such a long time to shape
they look just like the ones you were at
a restaurant
i love kimchi and it just all gives it
this really
rich flavor but this is like the perfect
amount of spice with the pork and the
vegetables inside it's really good
korean food
a-plus all right so the last dish i am
having joelle make today
is fufu and chicken soup there are so
many different
variations of soup in ghana and one
common one is something called a light
soup
and this specific one is chicken light
soup it is made with chicken
tomatoes onions a bunch of seasonings
all
boiled together to create this nice
light savory soup the soups can be eaten
with rice but
very commonly they are eaten with
something called fufu fufu
is this large mound of starchy dough
usually made out of plantain cassava or
coco yam and it is a very very common
thing to
eat with your soups and stews in ghana i
looked at
five different grocery stores in my area
went to every single little market i
could find
and none of them sold the flour if you
live in the bay area nowhere to get fufu
mix let me know because i'm kind of
bummed that i didn't get to make it
they're not too complicated but they can
be a little tricky
yeah i hope she has fun oh this smells
really good i love
like stewed anything honestly
[Music]
it's so yummy and like savory and the
flavor from the chicken with like
all the veggies seeps together so good
this is what i needed
at the end of a long day was just to
shove some chicken in my face
that is it that is everything all these
foods were
so wonderful and
scrumptious korean food is top tier
the recipes were great thank you elise
for challenging me and giving me all of
your incredible recipes that i got to
just attempt
i think that it's so fun to be able to
step outside of your comfort zone and
just try different cuisines
explore different aspects of other
people's cultures and this was
a delicious way to be able to do that so
it's such a wonderful privilege to be
able to learn about other cultures and
my favorite way to do that is through
food so
this was great and yeah